[Musique]
étranger
bonjour
nous avons une petite situation que nous
voulions gérer par toi Mobius wow super de
te revoir c'est ce qui se
passe wow
le temps glisse
les temps d'attente tu sais que oui tu as vu
ça ouais peux-tu réparer ça  non
c'est impossible de faire glisser le temps dans TVA
je sais mais on vient de le voir arriver
[Musique]
J'ai été tiré à travers le temps
entre le passé et le présent bonjour
si ce que j'ai vu est vrai
[Musique]
ce monde et les autres destructions n'en sont qu'un
une façon de découvrir
un bon travail à l'ancienne,
écoute, nous avons différents styles, tu es un
homme d'action, ce qui est bien,
j'adopte une approche cérébrale délibérée plus lente,
c'est vraiment une bonne chose,
[Musique]
c'est à nous
de sauver cet endroit, c'est ça  je l'ai craqué
quoi que nous fassions, nous
jouons à Dieu,
nous sommes des dieux
mais chérie, comment choisis-tu
qui vit
et qui meurt,
fais le choix difficile
[La musique]
arrive toujours,
sera toujours
bien exagérée, tu ne penses pas que je
pensais que c'était parfait  à l'
étranger